[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend unser planet schwebt in
lebensgefahr
sprach svenja schulze
bundesumweltministerin heute in berlin
in ihrer reaktionen auf den neuen
bericht der weltweit wichtigsten
experten planet in lebensgefahr
dieser satz spricht eher für politischen
frust als für eine sachliche analyse der
planet erde wird zweifellos nach
unzähligen natürlichen auch den
menschgemachten klimawandel überleben
was die aktuellen nachrichten bilder
zeigen ist wie arques menschen ihre
eigene lebensgrundlage in gefahr
gebracht haben indem sie falsches getan
und richtiges unterlassen haben deshalb
beginnt bei uns oliver heuchert mit dem
was jetzt schon stattfindet der kampf
gegen die flammen konzentriert sich
mittlerweile auf den norden der
griechischen insel euböa feuerwehrleute
und freiwillige in der nähe des ortes
elemica versuchen am boden die brände
einzudämmen
und auch was der luft kommt wasser höher
ist die zweitgrößte griechische insel
liegt nah am griechischen festland wir
kämpfen gegen zwei feuerfronten auf
euböa im norden und im süden der insel
durch starke winde angefacht bedrohen
die flammen zahlreiche orte wir
bekämpfen nonstop am boden und auch aus
der luft weil hunderte familien ihr
zuhause und ihre habe verloren haben
sammeln freiwillige spenden um die
obdachlosen zu versorgen die erste not
zu lindern wie hier in der nähe des
antiken olympia auf der halbinsel
peloponnes
wenn die brände gelöscht sind werden die
schäden deutlich wird klar was alles
zerstört wurde
dutzende orte liegen in trümmern häuser
geschäfte einfach kaputt
tausende hektar wald vernichtet es wird
jahre dauern
all dies wieder aufzubauen auf
thorsten von den finanziellen schäden
ganz zu schweigen
da wo die flammen endgültig gelöscht
sind beginnt das aufräumen marily zur
post at betreibt im sommer ein kleines
hotel in psg auf das feuer und seine
folgen muss die frankfurterin erst noch
verarbeiten
unser gefällig wir haben sehr große
angst für unsere unser gebäude für unser
dorf und für die ganze gegend wir sind
natürlich glücklich dass wir wenigstens
das mit der gebäude geschafft haben
von der anderen seite der lgs gibt es
heute gute nachrichten an der westküste
der türkei werden mittlerweile
zahlreiche lösch hubschrauber und
flugzeuge gegen die verbliebenen feuer
eingesetzt
die feuerwehren haben die brände hier
weitgehend unter kontrolle
es ist natürlich dass wir in europa
gerade stärker auf das katastrophale
geschehen um das nahe mittelmeer schauen
aber es ist auch für uns wichtig zu
erkennen dass die lage in ferneren ecken
der welt ganz ähnlich ist wie in den
weiten sibiriens oder gerade heute
wieder im norden von kalifornien im
ganzen landschaften bietet das dixi
feier eines der größten in der
geschichte kaliforniens die historische
goldgräberstadt greenville hat das feuer
fast völlig zerstört für kommende woche
werden erneut hohe temperaturen erwartet
bis zu 38 grad
es war nicht so geplant dass die
aktuelle ehrt um spannende studie über
das globale klima geschehen gerade heute
raus kommt in dieser lag da steht nun
alles was wir als menschheit wissen oder
glauben zu wissen über das was auf uns
zukommt was im moment passiert wurde vor
jahrzehnten entschieden mehr oder minder
ahnungslos jetzt entscheidet sich wie
die erde in der mitte und am ende dieses
jahrhunderts aussehen wird christine
elsner und marco berichten
sturm starkregen dürre und
überschwemmungen
inzwischen bleibt keine region des
planeten mehr von den folgen der
erderwärmung verschont so deutlich wie
nie macht der weltklimarat in seinem
neuen bericht die von menschen
freigesetzten treibhausgase
verantwortlich um 1,1 grad hat sich das
klima seit mitte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts schon erwärmt tendenz
steigend wenn der treibhausgas ausstoß
weiter zunimmt werden es nach den
berechnungen bis 2100 vier bis fünf grad
sein
mit den aktuellen klimaschutz plänen
würde der temperaturanstieg etwa drei
grad betragen und das pariser klima
limit von maximal 2 grad das ist
rechnerisch noch schaffbar erklärt ein
co autor des neuen berichtes für mich
ist die wichtigste aussage dass wir die
ziele des pariser klimaabkommens
verfehlen werden außer hier fangen
sofort an den ausstoß von treibhausgasen
zu reduzieren
so oder so werden die extremwetter
ereignisse erst mal zu nehmen und sie
werden stärker werden bei manchen
effekten hilft auch klimaschutz nur noch
wenig manches ist zwar umkehrbar aber
gerade die erwärmung der ozeane das
abschmelzen der großen eisschilde auf
grönland und der antarktis das ist über
jahrhunderte nicht mehr umkehrbar das
gilt auch für den meeresspiegel jährlich
steigt der immer schneller an
bis 1971 waren es noch 1,3 mm zwischen
2006 und 2008 10 schon 3,7 millimeter
pro jahr ein anstieg um zwei meter bis
zum ende des jahrhunderts ist nicht
ausgeschlossen
ein klarer alarmruf auch an die politik
die industrie muss co2 frei werden wir
werden aus atomenergie und aus kohle
verstromung aussteigen und setzen auf
erneuert
jahre energien und das wirklich nach
vorne zu treiben das ist ganz zentral
und da muss die nächste regierung auch
für beschleunigung sorgen und auch
klimaaktivisten gretel bergmann
es liegt an uns mutig zu sein und
basierend auf den in diesen berichten
bereitgestellten wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen entscheidungen zu treffen
entscheidungen die auf dem
weltklimagipfel in glasgow im november
fallen könnten für die verhandlungen
dort soll der neue bericht eine solide
grundlage seien in deutschland haben
klimaveränderungen längst begonnen sagt
astrid kinderschar eine physikerin und
co-autorin des weltklimaberichts sie
spricht später im heute update gegen
23.50 mit nazan göttinger politische
parteien haben konjunkturen wie manche
branchen in wirtschaftszyklen verbrechen
und terrorakte stärken law and order
parteien wirtschaftlicher krisen
diejenigen mit einer starken sozialen
agenda außenpolitische bedrohungen die
mit starken persönlichkeiten denen mann
und frau den aufrechten gang gegenüber
einem putin ski oder beiden zutraut das
heißt die natur gerade bei uns vor führt
müsste eigentlich für den wahlkampf der
grünen zum beispiel erreichen aber die
wenigsten wählen eine partei nur wegen
eines themas einer person
da muss noch mehr zusammenkommen heute
war in hildesheim ein neuer
wahlkampfauftakt der grünen auch mit
robert habeck aber vor allen mit
annalena baerbock die nicht immer spitze
war in der vergangenheit und trotzdem
als spitzenkandidatin überzeugen muss es
gibt keine alternative mehr gleich
sprechen wir mit ihr erster bericht von
thomas reichert ein bisschen heimspiel
muss es dann schon sein nachhall dem
stolpern und den patzern ihrer
kanzlerkandidatin gehen die grünen ins
ziemlich grüne hildesheim coburg in der
nähe groß geworden ist
habeck und sie viele der 800 0 robert
und anna-lena sind und wo das wort
wahlkampf auftakt für bebo klingen mag
wie die hoffnung auf eine zweite eine
letzte chance dann denkt man wir machen
das so dann ist es nicht gut gelaufen
weil man selber auch fehler macht aber
frag ich mich in dem moment was heißt
das jetzt geben wir auf nein wir geben
nicht auf es ist ein sehr flüchtiges
eingeständnis besonders für die
unentschlossenen die skeptischen ich
glaube nicht dass ich die grünen wähle
und warum ich weiß es noch nicht weil
annalena baerbock ein bisschen vertrauen
verspielt hat für andere aber liegt die
schuld nicht bei den grünen sondern beim
politischen gegner
ich glaube ist das grünen feindliche
umfeld wenn man das so sagen kann
einfach
freie eben in vielen köpfen das bild der
grünen als partei und nicht als partei
die vielleicht einen fortschritt für
unser land erzählen möchte die grüne
spitze sieht das ähnlich der union
werfen sie einen schmutzigen wahlkampf
vor erklären sich selbst zum underdog
und setzten alles auf diese letzten
sieben wahlkampfwochen wir sagen auch
nicht dass wir die waadt mit löffeln
gefressen haben
was wir einfach nicht mehr zulassen
werden ist kritisiert zu werden für
antworten die wiedergeben von parteien
die nichts auf der pfanne haben diese
antwort wohl zusammen gegen die anderen
und nein öffentlich gibt es außer der
abstandsregel keine distanz zwischen
bernburg und habeck
es bleibt ihm ja auch nichts anderes
übrig ihre hoffnung ist dass sie ihn am
ende die großen themen des wahlkampfs
auftritt geben die klimafrage
zuallererst wir schützen denn wir das
klima schützen uns die offene die freie
gesellschaft unser leben unser glück
unser zusammenhalt die grünen
versprechen nichts weniger als eine
bessere zukunft eine rettung vor den
düsteren prognosen des weltklimarates es
ist auch ein appell an die ängste der
bürger von neuen wetterkatastrophen wenn
wir abwarten dann werden diese
extremwetterereignisse zu nehmen und wir
können uns nicht gegen jedes hochwasser
gegen jeden sturzregen gegen jetzt ein
hitze brand versichern sondern wir
müssen jetzt alles dafür tun dass sich
diese krisen nicht verschärfen
nach wochen der pannen im kleinen hoffen
die grünen das nun mit den ganz großen
themen wir stotternder wahlkampf endlich
fahrt aufnimmt guten frau baerbock
schönen guten abend wie war das heute in
hildesheim haben sie neuen wind unter
ihren flügeln gespürt das war der
auftakt in unsere wahlkampftour wo wir
deutlich machen dass es jetzt richtig um
veränderungen geht wir haben das ja
gerade im beitrag zu beginnen gesehen
dass wir jetzt die weichen dafür stellen
müssen dass wir auch in zukunft in
sicherheit leben in freiheit leben und
vor allen dingen diese klimakrise in
griff bekommen
das haben sie so ungefähr in unserem
letzten gespräch vor vielen wochen auch
schon gesagt ich wollte den neuen wind
beschrieben sehen gab es den
naja politik lebt davon dass sie
wirklich visionen hat dass sie ziele hat
und das dann auch umsetzt wenn ich jetzt
vor vier wochen was anderes erzählt als
heute dann ist das für mich keine
glaubwürdige politik weil wir wissen ja
nicht erst dem pc sie von heute dass die
klimakrise wirklich dramatisch ist
sondern jahren und deswegen braucht die
bundesregierung die auch wirklich
wirklich handeln sie hatten vor einigen
wochen damals hatten sie durchaus nach
den umfragen aussicht zu einer
historischen figur zu werden
die erste regierungschefin und das gilt
für männer wie frauen erster
regierungschef auch eines großen
industrielandes aus der grünen
weltbewegung ist das heute aus ihrer
sicht noch drin spüren sie das noch in
sich dieser wahlkampf macht deutlich
dass alles drin ist wir stehen vor einer
richtigen richtungswahl
es geht jetzt darum ob wir eine politik
machen die vorausschau auf die mutig
veränderung angeht und die vor einigen
mit der breite gesellschaft politik
macht das heißt nicht nur für einzelne
gruppen in der gesellschaft sondern für
den stahlarbeiter für die pendlerinnen
für die erzieherin für alle menschen in
unserem land und dafür braucht
leidenschaft und die bringe ich nach wie
vor dafür ein für diese großen großen
veränderung sie machen das was alle
parteien machen sie sagen klimaschutz
ist notwendig das wird allgemein auch
geglaubt und sie sagen wir haben ein
rezept das für alle ein gewinn ist das
widerspricht jeder lebenserfahrung bei
solchen grund stürzen den dingen gibt es
immer auch menschen die am ende bezahlen
müssen die erstmal opfer bringen müssen
sind sie bereit darüber auch mal zu
reden
ja das tun wir wir haben nie gesagt dass
klimaschutz mit dem finger schnippt
funktioniert aber was es braucht ist
eine politik die rahmenbedingungen setzt
und die unterschiedlichkeit der menschen
sieht weil zum glück sind nicht alle
menschen gleich in unserem land deswegen
muss ich doch schauen was bedeutet guter
klimaschutz für diejenigen die sofort
sich eine neue innovation kaufen können
und für diejenigen die nicht soviel geld
haben und darauf politik auszurichten
alle im blick zu haben
aber die großen veränderungen mutig
anzugehen und dafür die
rahmenbedingungen zu setzen das ist
aufgabe für mich für eine zukunftsfähige
politik
was ist denn so mutig an einer politik
die
verspricht wir verändern die welt zum
besseren um niemand zahlt drauf
einige werden ja zahlen insbesondere die
die viel co2 ausstoßen
aber damit es dann für alle tragbar ist
müssen wir schauen wie wir diese
mehrbelastung gerecht verteilen und
deswegen sagen wir dass wir das co2
preisgeld pro kopf wieder verteilen dann
tun wir nicht nur was für den
klimaschutz sondern eben auch für eine
soziale gerechtigkeit in diesem land das
ist für mich sozial gerechter klima
wohlstand und an dem zu bauen ist die
aufgabe für das nächste jahrzehnt
wir haben immer wieder gesehen dass die
menschen inzwischen gerade nach den
letzten ereignissen an die notwendigkeit
des klimaschutzes glauben aber die
grünen werden trotzdem obwohl sie die
klimaschutz partei ist mit ein bisschen
verdacht gesehen dass die dieses ziel
vielleicht zu absolut nehmen unbedingt
wollen und zum schluss geht das auf
kosten von mir zum beispiel sagt jeder
einzelne für sich und da hätten
vielleicht andere politiker die
jahrzehnte erfahrung als minister als
ministerpräsident haben die bei parteien
sind die klimawandel nicht immer schon
absolut gesehen haben vielleicht doch
sicherer aufgehoben
das ist ein gefühl mit dem sie im
wahlkampf fertig werden müssen
wie gehen sie das an der wand für
erneuerung steht dann geht es natürlich
dass man bereit erklärt wohin wir wollen
und wie man das gestalten will
aber wir haben ja gesehen dass die
rezepte der vergangenheit definitiv dazu
führen dass wir sicherheit schaffen dass
wir halt schaffen
sonst stünden wir aber der klimakrise ja
nicht da wo wir heute stehen und einfach
nur am status quo festzuhalten führt uns
dazu dass es im süden europas brennt
dass es bei uns extreme niederschläge
gibt die menschen in not bringen wo
menschen sogar sterben und zugleich
sehen wir doch eine industrie die sagt
wir haben jetzt die technologie dass wir
wirklich den durchbruch schaffen können
und das gilt es jetzt dafür die weichen
zu stellen dazu sagen wo es hart wird
das ist der umbau dieser industrie
arbeitsplätze und dafür habe ich einen
pakt vorgeschlagen
eben die industrie dabei zu unterstützen
dass die arbeitsplätze in deutschland in
europa bleiben aber einfach zu sagen wir
machen weiter wie bisher
das wird uns nicht nur in eine unsichere
zukunft führen sondern das gefährdet die
freiheit unserer kinder und unsere enkel
noch eine frage mit ganz kurzer
antwortmöglichkeit wie dankbar sind sie
ihrem partner robert habeck dafür dass
er nicht in seiner macht und offen sagt
ich wäre schon der bessere kandidat
gewesen
dieses team funktioniert seit drei
jahren und das ist auch was in der
bundesregierung führen wollen nicht nur
einer steht vorne sondern die großen
herausforderungen können wir nur an
gehen gemeinsam im team
und deswegen zeigt sich dass eine
doppelspitze auch eine ganz gute idee
sein kann im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert sie hätten neben danke sagen
können ich kann mit ihrem verlust
geschrieben
danke und ein schöner und nachrichten
hier nun von gundula knapp einen monat
nach der hochwasserkatastrophe hat
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
laschet einen wiederaufbau fonds von 20
bis 30 milliarden euro gefordert
allein in nrw beliefen sich die
gesamtschäden nach ersten ermittlungen
auf mindestens 13 milliarden euro
in rheinland pfalz sei mit einer
ähnlichen wenig höheren summe zu rechnen
der landtag von nordrhein-westfalen
gedachte in einer sondersitzung der
todesopfer und betroffenen
bei der unwetterkatastrophe mitte juli
waren mindestens 180 menschen ums leben
gekommen
47 von ihnen in nordrhein westfalen
bund und länder beraten morgen über die
flut hilfen und über das weitere
vorgehen in der pandemie dabei mehren
sich forderungen aus union und spd
dass ungeimpfte künftig für corona tests
zahlen müssen
das robert koch institut meldet 1183
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
336 mehr als vor einer woche zwei
weitere todesfälle gibt es im
zusammenhang mit 19 auf 23,1 ist die
sieben tage incidents gestiegen
die spitzen von cdu spd und fdp in
sachsen anhalt haben sich auf den
entwurf eines koalitionsvertrages
einigt bei cdu und spd müssen noch die
mitglieder entscheiden
bei der fdp ein parteitag stimmen alle
zu könnte die neue koalition am 16
september den amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten haseloff erneut zum
regierungschef wählen
es wäre die erste koalition aus cdu spd
und fdp
seit über 60 jahren die radikal
islamischen taliban sind in afghanistan
weiter auf dem vormarsch
innerhalb von vier tagen haben sie mit
eibach im norden des landes die sechste
provinzhauptstadt erobert am wochenende
hatten die taliban bereits kundus unter
ihre kontrolle gebracht
dort hatte die bundeswehr jahrelang
gegen die taliban gekämpft
tausende zivilisten in afghanistan sind
vor den islamisten auf der flucht
heute vor einem jahr war der neunte
august ein sonntag ein tag der der welt
hätte zeigen können wie der demokratie
eine revolution gelingt in freier
gleicher geheimer wahl kreuzen auf
papier wahlurnen unparteiisch ausgezählt
es geht um belarus
die hinweise sind überwältigend dass
sich diktator lukaschenko damals nach
statistischen eine statistische methode
ein wunschergebnis hat auszählen lassen
da schlug dann erst richtig die stunde
der auf recht mutigen demokratinnen ein
hunderttausende ging für ihre wahl auf
die straßen getragen von überzeugungen
und hoffnung
das hätte ein friedlicher triumph werden
können es hat am ende nicht gereicht
heute ein jahr nach dieser wahl hat die
staatsgewalt wohl erst einmal gesiegt
der mut der menschen die sanktionen des
westens haben das nicht verhindern
können sogar berichtet über eine
bedrückende bilanz
zum großen gespräch lädt alexander
lukaschenko heute in den münster
unabhängigkeit palast alle fragen seien
erlaubt betont der belarussische
machthaber sind sie zu kritisch nimmt
lukaschenko das allerdings persönlich
diese gemeinheiten die sie mir entgegen
schleudern
sie nennen mich diktator aber hören sie
um eine diktatur zu führen braucht man
ressourcen
ich bin ein ziemlich vernünftiger mensch
mir ist klar man braucht ressourcen und
die haben sie nicht von der geplanten
verfassungsreform bis zu einem
unionsstaat mit russland reichen die
themen und natürlich geht es um die
präsidentschaftswahl die sich heute
jährt aber so stark manipuliert wurde
dass europa und die usa sie nicht
anerkennen es ist unmöglich mit diesem
regime zu verhandeln
dieser präsident ist zu unrecht in
island und seine macht stützt sich nur
auf gewalt folter und repression mythos
verändere crashes rückblick 80 bin
lukaschenko bei den wahlen erreicht
haben
wochenlange massenproteste brechen aus
für einen demokratischen wandel
lukaschenko seit über einem
vierteljahrhundert an der macht lässt
auf sein volk einschlagen erweitert in
den kommenden monaten sein netz an
repression
zu den wenigen bälle russinnen die sich
noch trauen offen zur opposition zu
stehen gehört tatiana hat zur an bord
ist uns erwartet noch schlimmeres noch
mehr repressionen haftstrafen
säuberungen es sei denn die
wirtschaftliche lage verschlechtert sich
so dass die machthaber ihre strategie
ändern müssen deswegen ruhen große
hoffnungen der belarussischen opposition
auf sanktionen
dass großbritannien und die usa heute
neue strafmaßnahmen gegen belarus
verhängt haben erfährt lukaschenko
während der achtstündigen
pressekonferenz ersticken sie doch an
diesen sanktionen lukaschenko
präsentiert sich selbstbewusst teilt aus
in richtung westen
sehen sie die westlichen länder werden
den dritten weltkrieg entfesselt
warum schreiben sie uns und die russen
dazu wollen sie diesen krieg gewinnen es
wird keine gewinner geben und wenn doch
dann nicht sie so klingt einer der
russland fest an seiner seite weiß
der preis dafür wird so meinen viele
politische beobachter womöglich die
unabhängigkeit seines landes sein
zurück nach deutschland und damit in den
wahlkampf da hat die linkspartei ein
seit jahren wachsendes problem sie muss
sich den bestand an wählern den jenseits
von komplizierten einzelfragen die ganze
richtung nicht passt teilen mit der
konkurrenz von ganz rechts
das bekommt den chancen der linken nicht
so gut sie muss ein profil zeigen dass
die afg nicht bietet umverteilen soziale
programme für die den am meisten fehlt
bezahlt von denen die am meisten haben
per gesetz andreas huppert erzählt dass
anhand einer frau der linken die in
ihrem wahlkreis immer und immer wieder
die mehrheit gewonnen hat die also
offenbar weiß wie es geht
berlin stadtteil lichtenberg tief im
osten der hauptstadt
das ist ihr wahlkreis gesine lötzsch von
den linken seit fast 20 jahren ist sie
im bundestag hat immer das direktmandat
gewonnen
die linke kommt hier bei den wählern an
die mehrheit der menschen hier wohnt
muss für ihr geld wirklich hart arbeiten
und malochen und selbst dann reicht es
manchmal nicht über den ganzen monat
die meisten die hier leben sind also
keine großverdiener normalos eben
zwischen all den plattenbauten weniger
steuern und gerechtigkeit ist ein großes
thema weil es auch hier eine menge leute
gibt die kleine jobs haben die von mini
jobs leben müssen und das ist einfach
eine unterstützung für das normale leben
und jeder soll ja im leben so teilnehmen
können das auch was von seinem leben hat
die stimme der kleinen leute das ist der
anspruch und so präsentiert die partei
auch ihr neues steuerkonzept die oberen
einkommen belasten die unteren und
mittleren einkommen entlasten
alle bis 6500 euro werden entlastet man
kann sagen die durchschnittsverdiener in
deutschland bekommen 100 euro monatlich
mehr nach unserem konzept und so soll es
finanziert werden
der spitzensteuersatz wird von 42 auf 53
prozent angehoben ab einem zu
versteuernden einkommen von ca 76.000
euro für singles auch die sogenannte
reichensteuer soll von jetzt 45 auf 60
prozent steigen bei ledigen mit einem
jahreseinkommen von ca 278.000 euro ab
einer million werden dann 75 prozent
fällig der cdu-generalsekretär nennt
solche pläne schlichtweg enteignung
wehren alles ab wirken wo jetzt die
chancen liegen wieder zu neuem wohlstand
auch klimaneutral im wohlstand zu kommen
und deswegen sind die pläne der linken
das ist eine fortschreibung ihrer
bisherigen konzeption von enteignungen
doch die linke will noch mehr eine
corona vermögensabgabe für millionäre um
damit einen teil der pandemie kosten zu
tilgen bei einem vermögen von über 2
millionen euro zehn prozent ab 50
millionen sondern es dann 30 prozent
steuerlast sein
das würde einen namen
310 milliarden bringen und würde nur 0,7
prozent der bevölkerung treffen also
hier klar und eindeutig die belastung
der groß vermögenden in unserem land die
spd will sich diese pläne nicht zu eigen
machen der kanzlerkandidat kommentiert
sie eher schmallippig die spd hat ein
sehr gutes ausgewogenes konzept und das
ist besser
übrigens der soli soll wieder eingeführt
und für alle beibehalten werden auch das
gehört zu den steuerplänen der links
hier im lichtenberger kiez dürfte das
alles gut ankommen gesine lötzsch setzt
darauf hofft so auf das direktmandat im
wahlkreis 86 dann zum sechsten mal in
folge das biotechnologieunternehmen
biontech hat aktuelle zahlen vorgelegt
und die sind wie erwartet glänzend der
korona impfstoff brachte der mainzer
pharmafirma einen enormen sprung bei
umsatz und gewinn
frank bethmann ein blick in die zukunft
was ist weiter von biontech zu erwarten
wenn man sich hier so umhört dann doch
eine ganze menge biontech hat seinen
umsatz inzwischen verhundertfacht und
hebt seine prognose für umsatz und
gewinn weiter deutlich an
derzeit profitieren die mainzer auch
davon dass in ländern wie israel bereits
dritt impfungen mit dem impfstoff
anlaufen
für die dritt impfung die noch höheren
schutz bieten soll hat bei montech
inzwischen auch eine zulassung bei den
europäischen und amerikanischen behörden
beantragt doch bayern trägt das ist
längst nicht nur corona schutz der
konzern forscht mittlerweile auch an
anderen impfstoffen auf m rna basis an
wirksamen injektionen gegen grippe
malaria und verstärkt jetzt auch wieder
an therapien gegen krebs mit einem
durchbruch hier bei der krebsbekämpfung
würde das unternehmen endgültig in die
erste liga der pharmakonzerne aufsteigen
die aktie hat diese entwicklung längst
vorweggenommen seit beginn der korona
pandemie kletterte das papier um weit
über 1000 prozent nach oben
bei ontex erfolg rechnet sich im übrigen
auch für den finanzminister auf seinen
gewinnen hat das mainzer unternehmen
nämlich inzwischen mehr steuern gezahlt
als zuvor an fördergeldern ja
hat frank bethmann vielen dank ja das
olympia-team deutschland ist aus tokio
zurückgekehrt den zuletzt noch rund 120
athleten trainer und betreuer ihnen
wurde auf dem frankfurter römer ein
stimmungsvoller empfang bereitet corona
gerecht waren nur etwa 500 fans
zugelassen
wegen der pandemie waren zuvor schon
alle athleten zurückgereist die ihre
wettbewerber bereits beendet hatten
deutschland war bei den olympischen
spielen mit 37 medaillen 9 beste nation
geworden
es ist das schlechteste ergebnis seit
der wiedervereinigung aber ein schöner
empfang und ein schönes bild das war es
erst einmal von uns bis zum update von
nazan glückte mia in einer guten stunde
23 50 und gesang es morgens
[Musik]
genau dies hatten wir in diesem sommer
ja schon genug und auch aktuell sehen
tiefs über uns hinweg die bringen heute
einige schauer und gewitter von westen
aber sie sehen auch hier gibt es ein
neues hoch das heißt 11 und das bringt
uns spätestens zur wochenmitte dann den
hochsommer nach ganz deutschland wo wir
den regen deutlich brauchen könnten das
wäre ja hier in der türkei in
griechenland und auch in süditalien der
fall da ist es aber zurzeit
knochentrocken und daran wird sich auch
nichts ändern und auch morgen steigen
dort die temperaturen auf 35 bis 40 grad
der weil es in nord- west- und
mitteleuropa mit 15 bis 25 grad kühler
ist heute nacht sinken die temperaturen
in der oberpfalz bis 9 grad an der
nordseeküste bleibt bis abbildet mit 15
grad
dazu gibt es zum teil klaren
sternenhimmel hier zum beispiel nördlich
von berlin am main oder auch am
alpenrand und am bodensee am anfang der
nacht gibt es noch einige regenschauer
in norddeutschland und in der zweiten
nachthälfte ziehen dann hier im westen
schon die ersten gewitter auf und diese
gewitter breiten sich dann im laufe des
morgigen tages weiter nach osten aus
dazwischen zeigt sich auch mal die sonne
zuschauer dabei und dass man einen recht
kräftigen wind aus südwestlichen
richtungen
südlich von main und mosel zeigt sich
dagegen die sonne häufiger bei west wird
dort steigen die temperaturen morgen
genauso wie in sachsen auf 25 bis 28
grad sonst bleibt es noch kühler aber
bis zur wochenmitte erreichen wir dann
doch recht häufig die 30 grad guten ab